good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-suffolk District
Council cabinet
I'm councilor Susie Morley the leader of
mid-suffolk District Council and I'm
chairing this meeting this morning
first to remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
and also your laptops
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please could members make sure they're
logged in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
can I now move to the agenda please
item one is apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councilor Fleming
councilor Brewster and councilor Gould
and Council well only chair and of
overview and scrutiny committee has also
forwarded apologies
thank you very much item 2 is to receive
Declarations of pecuniary other
registerable or non-registerable
interest by members are there any to
declare
all right
thank you item three
MCA slash 22 47 to confirm the minutes
of the meeting held on the 6th of
February 2023 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
could I have a proposal please
councilor Richardson and seconding
councilor flatman
um
I think we can do this by vote show of
hands
that's what's for chair that's unanimous
thank you very much
thank you
item four is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme not received
item five questions by counselors thank
you chair and unreceived
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committee they are
nomaders referred to chair thank you
thank you item seven forthcoming
decisions list are there any uh comments
thank you very much
item eight is MCA slash 22-48 is the
general fund Financial monitoring report
for 2022-23 quarter three
invite counselor Whitehead the cabinet
member for finance to introduce this
report councilor Whitehead
uh thank you madam chairman um so the
first of my two reports today I'd like
to introduce the general fund Financial
monitoring for quarter three 2223
so it's based on nine months of actual
financial data from April to December 22
which was used to forecast the outcome
for the full year 22-23
report also sets out to explain any
significant variances against budget
members will note the new format that
we've introduced this report compared to
the previous quarterly monitoring
reports all the detailed information is
now contained in the appendix with the
numbers and explanations set out side by
side in landscape format and I trust
members will find this a presentational
Improvement
in the quarter two out term report we
were forecasting a net expenditure
overspend of 839 000 which was
marginally up from the quarter one
forecast with the benefit of extra three
months of actual data we revised that
net expenditure overspend down to 548
000.
the bulk of that is covered by the
inflationary pressures reserve of 500
000 we brought forward from 2122
this leaves just 48 000 to be offset
against the growth and efficiency fund
this means that the vast bulk of the
large Surplus we forecast for 2223
remains intact
the amount that we set aside in 2223 for
the commercial development risk Reserve
of 1.865 million is also no longer
required even the successful sale and
receipt on Gateway 14 from the range
and this Reserve can now be repurposed
I'm happy to answer any detailed
questions that members may have on the
varying schedules that build up the
overspend position by individual
Department however I trust major
variance commentary that the finance
team has provided alongside the numbers
already gives a great deal of
explanation
within the appendix to the report is
also a schedule of general fund Revenue
reserves which total over 22 million
after committed funds are taken into
account
appendix also includes a line-by-line
general fund Capital forecast and again
I have to answer any questions members
may have on that Capital forecast
possibly I do wear necessary on some of
the finer detail by our finance team
present today
but I'd like to move the recommendations
set out in paragraph three
that we note only at this stage the
forecasted overspend the reserves
movement and revised Capital program I
would ask for a second thank you
Council I wanted to uh councilor
Richardson
thank you chair happy to second that
do I have any questions from candidate
do I have any questions from anybody
else
cancer field
yes I suppose first of all I want to say
we do welcome the new format that is an
improvement I think
um I always get good to have a lot of
detail to get lost in but um
and many of these numbers we've seen you
know we've questioned before so I won't
go through endless questions just really
the issue is that the overspend
improving getting less
which
clearly is a good thing I'm going to see
it going in the opposite direction but
we have pointed out on many occasions
that the district regularly improves its
financial position as you approach the
year end and the concern is that by
being too pessimistic about that early
on you know one makes other decisions
with a
a less generous head-on
so the real question is
are you
you're happy that the forecasting is as
accurate it could as it could reasonably
be that
this stage improving by around 300 000
is a good thing but is that biased
decisions in the way we wouldn't desire
the last time when we looked to the
budget which was only a couple of weeks
ago
are you satisfied that we we've got
you've got this right and that we're not
still being too pessimistic about uh
income and uh and overestimating uh
outgoings as
actually through the year
I think you've Council field
um yeah these last couple of budgets
we've really tried hard not to uh sort
of be over uh pessimistic line by line
because obviously if you do that then
the overall position gets the situation
where we saw perhaps in the past where
we had two or three million pound
surpluses against budget and I mean the
fact that we've um coming in with
overspends now tends to suggest that um
we're you know we've possibly even gone
too far too far the other way but
um
it's good to see things are improving
from quarter three to Quarter Two and
I'd like to think that rather than it
just being a case of um
um getting the numbers finer you know
also the officers are looking at these
um at their individual departments
quarter by quarter seeing where
overspends are recurring or seeing where
there are items that um could be spent
that haven't been spent and basically
sort of fine-tuning so sort of using the
financial monitoring for the purpose
it's intended which is to sort of you
know steady and steer the course of the
the council
um you know in terms of um they're
always in such a complex budget that'll
always be the odd little error or odd
little oversight and um is a learning
position for for our finance team and
for the department managers but I'm
happy that things yeah are on improving
Trend and um I think we've got a good
handle on our finances
sort of a slightly
wider question
obviously this sort of improvement can
be just because there's a whole raft of
say contracts uh
won't go on
a range of examples but but just the
issue is what should we be looking here
at here what should we be telling our
Parish councils or whatever our
residents that has changed is there any
clear
single issue you know something we
aren't misestimated something that
hasn't come in on time or is it a whole
raft of different
model items
well clearly the budget was produced
back in well well it was approved in
February 22 which means that a lot of
the work was done even before that and
certainly the cost living crisis and so
which has gone on economically in the
world since the start of 22 has had a
major effect
um personally I think
we're getting through the worst of it
now and um some forecasts are saying
that um you know inflation should get
back to you've been on track
pretty early in 24.
and the interest rates if they haven't
peaked yet I've peaking very soon so um
I think the message to parishes is
there's still a big we're still showing
a good Surplus on our
this year's figures we've got um
surfacing budgets and the four-year
Outlook and we've Frozen council tax for
two years on the truck and things look
pretty Rosy I think
I think also your your assertion that
the underspend is due to projects not
being completed is generally not true
it's more because of our success in
getting external funding in to support
our our residents and our communities so
it's it's a testament to Our Success I
think rather than a failure of projects
yeah I did make that assertion I
suggested that was a possible reason
very pleased to hear it isn't thank you
Council Mellon
yeah thank you chair um yeah not my
colleague also welcome the new format
it's um makes it a bit easier for me to
understand it and I'm not
a kind of figures person
um my question is really about um
the the scale of the variances obviously
some of them are very minor
understandable some of them are you
quite quite big 26 percent uh 35 in one
Department
um
so just a couple of
questions drilling down into the detail
um
if that's okay
the Strategic property on page four of
the of the appendix
there's a a 49k overspend
um on the the changes in in the office
floor plate
um I kind of got the impression that
that was all going forward quite smooth
spending quite a bit extra there because
it's later than budgeted and then on
page five on the in the finance
commissioning and procurement section
the bank charges are 38k higher
than expected and I just wonder if
there's any explanation for that
obviously that's dealing with the you
know payments to the
to the council for council tax but it
seems to be quite a big figure over and
above what one would expect
foreign
property I mean this is one example that
perhaps Council the field could have
taken as one that had you know had
slipped a bit because I think the
intention originally was to be in on the
new floor plan
um prior to Christmas rather than I
think today is the sort of oh they say
this month is a sort of go live date
there so there has been slippage there
and there has been a crossover
um you know so that is just a fact of
life
um compared to you know what the
budgeted timetable I said it was put
together some a long while ago in terms
of the bank charges of 38 000 over and I
think I'd like to just um pass that
across to offices for a little
explanation if possible
thank you thank you chair um yeah on the
bank charges it's to do with the types
of transactions that we're now seeing
coming through so uh credit cards
carries a higher Bank charge and we're
seeing a large volume of those now
coming through compared to what we
budgeted for so we are keeping an eye on
that we're keeping that under review
um just to see what behaviors are
driving those payments to see what we
can do about that
thank you everybody
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay so the recommendations are that
subject to any further budget variations
that arise during the rest of the
financial year the net expenditure
overspend position of 500
and forecast Reserve movements referred
to an appendix a of the report be noted
and the revised
2021-22 Capital program referred to in
appendix a section 5 be noted
ask the governance officer to conduct a
vote thank you thank you chair the vote
is now in progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
that's unanimous
thank you
item 9 MCA slash 22 49 is the housing
revenue account Financial monitoring
system Financial monitoring for quarter
three for 20
um invite councilor Whitehead to
introduce this report
thank you madam chairman uh so please
now to report as I introduced the report
housing revenue account Financial
monitoring quarter three of 2223
so that's for the general fund we've got
nine months of actual data extra Triple
Eight forward for the current year
and as this is still a forward
projection rather than reporting
historical data the information is
simplificating only
so the forecast adapted for the year in
this quarter three extrapolation has
grown from the forecast in quarter one
and Quarter Two
the adverse variance to budget is now
927 000 compared to the 770 000 at the
quarter two stage and the 489 000 a
quarter one station clearly this is a
disappointing trend
so we're now forecasting a deficit out
of 832 000 compared to the budget
surplus of 95 000.
that's for the general fund presenting
the outturn in the new format that I
explained uh with the general fund
income variance is little change from
Quarter Two the housing management
adverse variance has moved out to 554
000 from 382 000 anticipating quarter
two but the explanation for the
variances are set out on the schedule
over nine bullet point headings
Building Services cost overrun compared
to budget is now 10.7 percent a little
higher than 9.5 anticipating Quarter Two
Pairs and maintenance and areas other
than the trade teams has decreased
producing a small positive variance
and further work on depreciation is up
that charge by 170 000 or 3.8 percent
based on 2223 evaluations
when we come to the final outturn
reporting in June and July I'd
anticipate some adjustments to interest
payable and to revenue contribution to
Capital but possibly some reductions in
the latter
the final schedule in the appendix
forecaster Capital spend
activity on new bills and Acquisitions
continues at PACE
spent 1.330 million in quarter one
5.494 million in quarter two four point
eight nine four million and quarter
three anticipate a further 8.987 million
in quarter four to give a total for the
year for new bills and Acquisitions of
20.705 million
members will see that after a project by
project review we've removed removed
some new build projects from the program
has not been deliverable in the medium
term
but beyond the short term I feel so much
awaits the new 30-year HRA business plan
and for now the numbers in this
monitoring report for noting only
I therefore like to propose the
recommendation set out in paragraph
three of the report
unless that they'd be seconded and I'm
happy to answer any questions members
may have
able to support the resourced by
officers from both finance and housing
teams thank you madam chairman
Council spending thank you very much do
we have any questions from cabinet
questions from anybody else
councilman
yeah thank you chair
um in the um section of the report on
environmental implications
um there's some details of
things that the council is doing uh to
as part of the carbon neutral agenda
um so 11.2 says that the Midsouth has
installed 87 air source heat pumps in
Castle owned homes but that's since 2020
so that figure seems a bit out of date
have we got something a bit more
up-to-date or perhaps for the last
all this current year and then it goes
on to say that
our new homes design and Technical
specification will be launched in 2022
so that is clearly
um
looking backwards I wonder whether this
section has kind of being cut and paste
from an old report or something
so that was my question
thank you well I was going to
confidently say that I would assume it's
up to date and that the figures in 11.2
are accurate but with your observations
about 11.5 and they here's the future
tense for a year that's gone by I think
I would just like to perhaps some pass
our level to officers just a comment on
the 87 and
um
believe that the Design Tech spec has
has been already launched but I'll pass
the left offices of May
um so so I'll need to get back to you on
the number of
um Asos heat pumps installed
um after
um 2020 although
um I don't think we will have done any
because of the covid restrictions but
I'll need to check that
I'm sorry just just what was your other
question
oh it's just that it's reporting
um as Future something that's obviously
in the past 11.5 oh yes okay so so
um the design and Technical
specification
um so as
um councilors alluded to we're yet to
write our new business plan we're hoping
to
um complete that this year um
on that we'll be able to
um you know put in place our new design
um specification however
um I'm pleased to be able to tell you
that that the the most efficient way
um of building is seen as passive house
um and and I'm sure that's something
will be uh paying high regard to
it does it
just to debate this item
oh sorry apologies Council field
question
um
just looking at the maintenance
budget you have here plan maintenance
3.4 roughly million
budget a carry forward of a million it
was a covid year not surprising a
current budget of therefore 4.48
actual today 1.776
bearing in mind this is this is nine
months
I think is is quite a substantial change
of a year full year forecast 3.264.
well you know thinking about uh accuracy
and forecasting Etc
how can we spend
1.776 in nine months and we're gonna up
that to
3.264 in the next three months
it seems sort of
to me quite a question
obviously they're carry forward is you
know that that sort of says that we're
not spending a rate higher than our
original budget which given Staffing
reduction restrictions and things may
well be fair but
really question are are they real
forecasts or is that
you know in any way sensible oh you're
actually accelerating work to that
extent
we believe all the others there's
similar things actually from point to
the tedious process of going through
them all there will be other things of
that nature the line below it for
instance as well have a similar
anger castlefield and I think that's a
very valid
observation you've made that um I think
as we get to the to the nine months
stage it does sort of tend to highlight
perhaps the um that um sometimes the
full year forecasts are a rather
aggressive moment I think I think as I
said when I introduced in terms of the
Capital spend on new bills we're sort of
accelerating that and have a high figure
in for the fourth quarter although I
believe that's a genuine one that um you
know in terms of programs come to
completion there but um I think in terms
of plan maintenance the explanation of
there is given in terms of some lack of
technological capacity to start with but
I think also with the lots of staffing
change that have gone on in the
housing team I think it's probably quite
right that there's probably a little bit
of a pause whilst um
um you know looking at how our plan
maintenance is being spent and directed
has been is being sort of reassessed
with them again I'm happy for the uh
director for housing to perhaps put her
own commentary on that if she wants
thank you
um producing a sound plan for plan
maintenance is
um as you're aware looking at our stock
and understanding
um what what the need is
um and and to do that we need
um
we need we need sound data to be able to
plan appropriately
um
we have got our transformation team in
as you're aware and Paul Crowe who is a
member of our transformation team has
also been cleansing the data
um required to put into place a new
program for Planned
um planned upgrades in our properties so
I can
um
can inform members that that is in place
and what we are now doing is we are
procuring contractors in able to who are
able to carry out that that work so I'm
confident that our planned program will
go ahead as budgeted
thank you you know yeah just to return
to that for a second if you look at the
other maintenance line
you've spent actual to date six hundred
and two thousand pounds in three
quarters
600 divided by three is 200 so you're
spending 200 000 a quarter
if I had 200 000 to 600 000 I get eight
hundred thousand for the year end now I
can't accept that you might have
accelerated something dramatically but
you know that really is very dramatic
is it real
I think as I said an customer my first
answer they um
um is certainly making very valid points
there and certainly when I when I tend
to review these schedules over whether
um you know quarter by quarter with our
final steam I I have to make the same
point but in in terms of
this information sort of feeds through
so I mean I'm not pointing the finger
there at the financing but in terms of
um
um I I you know hello to agree that it's
it looks aggressive but if if it isn't
spent by the 31st of March then it will
be carried forward and if it's spent on
the in April or May okay slightly
slightly delayed but at least the
capital's there for spending and it's
happening
fairly soon
watch this space I suppose you could say
thank you
um moving now into debate does anybody
wish to debate this item
so the recommendations are that subject
to any further budget variations that
arise during the rest of the financial
year the adverse variance of 927 000
pounds referred to in appendix a section
two of the report be noted
and the revised 2022-23
revised Capital program referred to an
appendix a Section 3 denoted and I'll
now ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
that is six votes four that's unanimous
thanks very much
item 10 is MCA slash 22 50. uh the
quarter three performance
this item is just for noting
just run through a summary of action
sorry
performance highlights
for
the customers
portfolio
so in quarter three there was an average
of 375 calls per day
and a total of 160 visits to the Stow
Market
access point over the period
the average wait time was 3 minutes and
44 seconds which is a decrease
from the previous quarter of from five
minutes and 11 41 seconds
and our officers and web team have
commenced training with Place Cube which
will help them to understand the new
website we've recruited 53 champions
from across the council to help with
rewriting our web content
to make sure that it's accessible and
fit for purpose
I'm going to ask each of the portfolio
holders in turn to summarize their
achievements over the previous quarter
start with economy councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair yes quarter
three was a busy month for the economy
portfolio with a number of different
projects on gang and several of those
actually we're we're seeing the fruits
of uh in in this quarter
um obviously the the the council will be
aware that we approved the Shelf project
or the initial business case for the
Shelf project at our full Council last
month a lot of work went into that in Q3
including the development of that
business case and the initial design
freeze for the scheme as a whole we also
continue to work on the development of
the skills and Innovation Center Gateway
14 again the initial business case for
that is on the agenda later today the
development also of the culture Heritage
and visitor economy strategy also on the
agenda today
um but also a number of of other
achievements in the quarter for example
the second Innovation Awards the first
one which was obviously in person and I
think those who attended would agree it
was a fantastic event we also had the
launch of KTP light which we've branded
as innovate to elevate we also had the
submission of the full business case of
Freeport East which of course as members
will be aware has subsequently been
approved by the treasury
um and then finally on quite a positive
uh note we launched the first schools
Enterprise challenge with uh hartersmere
school and by way of a very recent
update I'm delighted to say that I
visited hartismere school on Friday
morning to hand out the certificates to
the winners um
thank you Chad thank you councilor
Richardson
um communities portfolio councilor
flattman
sorry communities and well-being thank
you chair
so the uh spotlights on the community
grants uh are for
835 pans Capital grants allocation were
made last quarter and to 243
927 pounds spent on the 106 funds
allocated and 15 749 minor Grants
awarded and BC vcse organizations at the
voluntary organization
organizations supported through Revenue
grads
we've continued with um our locality
grants flying out the doors
um and the majority of mid-suffolk I
think has now been spent but they are
just finalizing the last figures for
that
Community safety and our anti-social
Behavior cases in 43
um six new ASB cases received
at the ASB partnership panels 27 New ASB
cases received separate to those
discussed with the ASB partnership
panels and one percent of the ASB cases
open more than six months
one ASB Community trigger called for the
anti-social Behavior ASB crime and
policing act 2014 introduced to
community trigger the trigger is
designed to give victims of ongoing ASB
the right to request a review of their
case and bring agencies together to take
a collaborative approach to finding a
solution
um
15 15 staff members from the communities
team supported the Suffolk owl sanctuary
as a local registered charity by
volunteering for the day which we are
rolling out through the organization so
staff can have a a day or so to help
register Charities this is being rolled
out across the organization for those
who want to take part which is fantastic
and
that was all about what we have done
obviously uh
today at this cabinet we will be
approving the upstate still bids
and also
we have
um
we are continue to Monitor and evaluate
the effective effectiveness of CCTV
cameras analyzing data and looking at
Trends and hot spots areas Hot Spot
areas and this will support the police
and also support Community engagement
events this is all carrying on
uh with the health and well-being
we had 112 children supported through
the holiday activity fund this was at
Christmas and half term and activities
um eight activities provision ran
through the holiday activity fund at
Christmas and
two Care Homes were supported through
dementia friendly offers okay so the the
Care Homes were supported with Omi board
which is a projector that is interactive
for
um for um
care care homes to use for them
for that for their in for their
customers which has been
financed by the camps so we have we have
um we have at least six and they're
making their way around mid-suffolk at
the moment which has been paid for by
some of us mid-suffolk X extra funds
that we've put in for well-being and
communities
um within this um
care home help for dementia we are also
this quarter
um going to look at the Archie project
which is where children from local
schools go in and spend time with the um
elderly
inmates of the homes and talk about
interesting things that the Elder
generation can tell the youngsters and
the youngsters work closely and this is
being rolled out across
some Care Homes and also different
schools have taken part which is
fantastic and uh the men the Care Homes
are finding this very beneficial
um
with the well-being we this quarter it's
all very well talking about last quarter
but this court you have that in front of
you this quarter we are carrying on with
our social subscribing and
you'll be able to publish that soon
which schools are going to be involved
with that
thank you thank you councilor Flatland
thank you
um so um performances remain steady
we've had um 55 cases where homelessness
has been successfully prevented or
relieved we've um the demand temporary
accommodation has increased since the
last quarter we've had 47 houses placed
into temporary accommodation
six houses and properties are being
roulette
and I'm 37 new affordable homes built
are required
um the the voids are still not as we'd
like to see them there's um 56 average
days for the voids to be re-let we've um
we've got a new voids and workflow
module in our open housing system which
means that all data and Road voids
progress can be now viewed within the
system rather than rather than a
spreadsheet which makes it easy to know
the status of any void property
and we're developing a new performance
data dashboards that we can track all
voids in the performance
continues on our migration to a new
housing system Capital One there has
been some delay to
shall we you know hopefully resolve this
summer you know as um there's some bugs
in the system but um but the that's now
with our software development team
Insight reporting dashboards project is
On Target and it's been delivered to HRA
and tenancy services this will allow all
managers to access all the reports they
need for their service area and run and
schedule reports themselves
work continues on the rents compliancy
audit to make sure our rents and charges
are compliant falling over from
cabinet's approval in November we've
launched our new tenant engagement
strategy tenants received a my home
bulletin in December to alert them that
the strategies be approved and there's
been a positive result response with
some tenants already coming forward to
become more involved and work with us
work continues with with our tenants
satisfaction collection
through both perception and
transactional surveys and the results
and feedback from the survey are now
being used to drive service improvement
the new web pages for our sheltered
housing scheme are now live and each
scheme has its own web page with a short
instruction video giving 10 prospective
tenants an idea of what's on offer
our plans for next quarter
um you know continues with the Building
Services transformation and Improvement
program following our self referral
myself referral to the regulator of
social housing which I'll touch on later
we continue to make good progress to
ensure all properties are fully
compliant with the regulatory standard
with only a very small small proportion
of waiting inspections there's also been
an overhaul of the existing processes
and there is now more robust data around
health and safety compliance to provide
tenants with complete reassurance
thank you Council for having him and for
the environment portfolio unfortunately
councilor Fleming can't be with us today
but the highlights from that are we've
completed the solar carport project and
we are now saving something in the
region of 62 tons of carbon per year as
a result of that project
and also we made a bid to the office of
zero emission vehicles for Ev charge
points and we were successful with that
we will be receiving 316
000 pounds worth of funding towards that
as well
so thank you councilors do we have any
questions
Council field
reluctant to go first again but still
um just the community grants area I
noticed you've you've recognized the
amount of section 106 funds that have
passed through the council
for six projects and I'm certainly aware
of 50 000 of that which your offices
pushed everybody
two two weeks from the deadline when it
disappeared back to the developers and
we've got that done so I can see there's
some good work going on there but I
would question just how much 106 funds
do we have uh outstanding that we're
we're holding on to for Community
projects I personally were aware of
another 400 000 which are for two things
in Council whiteheads area
and to the best of my knowledge they've
been sitting around since 2015 getting
making little progress so I think
there's some activity now so how much
have we got outstanding
and do we really have this sort of
effort behind this that we need of
course clearly some of these things are
complex to put together
I don't have the figures to hand
counselor field but I'm sure we can get
those to you Tom can you come in thank
you
um yes through you chair I don't have a
figure that tips my fingers but you can
find that out on the council's exorcom
website
um if you'd like me to go through that
with you then I can but that is
transparent and available on there as
s106 financials and you can go into any
individual Parish or Ward or across the
whole District
thank you thank you I appreciate that
but it's just an issue that this money
goes back to developers if we don't use
it so it is unlike cell which if we're
not very quick it just it just gains
interest this cash does
I think the thing about 106 is you can
only spend it on on certain projects so
I I mean I I'm sure the officers try not
to let any money go back to Developers
and we'll include a link to the external
database in the minutes
Council Mellon
um question on page 20 of the um
the quarterly report
um
it talks about an emerging project in
partnership with the County Council
virtus and the local Parish councils to
Pilot taxi bus
um
can I ask where this
um project has been initiated because
I'm struggling to find out from County
officials
and I haven't heard anything from our
staff on this I've only heard it from a
parish council clearly that area is is
where I represent as a county councilor
but it's not clear where that project is
being led from I understand there's a
possibly a meeting this Friday about it
but I'm not sure where or when and then
secondly just the sorry cancel sorry
councilman can you just tell me which
page you're referring to page 20.
it's in the community section uh it's
about halfway down the page
it's talking about emerging project or
proposal
I'm just going to bring in our officer
Fiona
yes it's uh it's a project that I
believe originated from discussions the
community were having um but Catherine
Davis our sustainable travel officer I
think has been attending or is about to
attend their meeting to find out a
little bit more and see how we can help
support it
um can I just move on to the next
paragraph down on that page whether it
is um
so this is um referring to a meeting
that took place with Parish councils at
one of one of our officers was there
where there's an identified need for
community Transport
um I wonder if this is a um a potential
uh place where our electric bus project
could fit in and wonder whether that
um the community's team are talking to
the people who are have got the funds
set aside for that and try and Link the
two up
I'm sure
um I'm sure the info I'm sure the
director of the economic growth
um and
um
the community's team do work together on
all these projects because we have done
on the electric bus etc etc so I expect
you are talking yeah lovely thank you
sorry does anybody wish to debate this
item
okay
so the recommendation is that quarter
three performance be noted thank you
very much everybody
moving on now to item 11.
this is MCA slash 22 51 the community
infrastructure Levy expenditure program
for March 2023. I'm going to invite the
cabinet member for planning to introduce
this report thank you councilman
thank you Jim oh dear
um
yes thank you to today we have um
six sill bids
um
to consider
affecting the parishes of holy
stradbroke
Stow Upland
hoxon Barham and Mendham
um
four of those bids are for Canada to
decide and two are simply for cabinet to
note because they're below the the
thresh
um
excuse me
and with the upper Mission chairman what
I will do is I'll um introduce the each
bid and then hand over to
the professional lead for
um
what is it professional need for key
sites and infrastructure uh to to give a
bit of detail around each one if that's
all right with you
thank you
okay the first the first one then is uh
bit number M22 hyphen 14 and it's
um
a play area in Hawley the sill bid
itself is for 70 71 000 pounds which
represents 70 percent of the total
eligible project costs
um so the professional lead for tea
sites and infrastructure will give a bit
of information on this particular bit
thank you
Council after consultation with
residents are proposing to upgrade their
current play area provision this will
provide greater choice and diversity for
outdoor play provision and exercise for
the children of the parish and provide
an outdoor space for families and social
groups to meet
project will provide new play equipment
including a pyramid climbing frame metal
combination swing set new multi-player
units new roundabout a new ground
surfacing to enable the site to be used
all year round the new operators will
increase the diversity of the quick the
equipment and therefore the overall
footfall to the play area site and the
project will use sustainable materials
to ensure longevity and easier
maintenance for the site thank you
thank you very much and the
recommendation is to cabinet for that is
to approve it please
the next one is M22 hyphen 26 which is
improvements to Chadbrook Health Center
the bid is for 29
724 pounds which represents 75 of the
total eligible costs
um the details are
thank you stradbroke Parish Council
owned part of stradbroke Health Center
parents are proposing to develop a
multi-phase project to extend and
improve the current health provision in
stradbroke the first phase will provide
an extension to the current Health
Center building
sill is assisting with the energy
Improvement and the second phase of the
project
this second phase will be looking to
deliver new solar panels roof lighting
and overall Improvement of systems that
heat the center The Works will enhance
the Energy Efficiency of the site
overall decreasing the carbon footprint
of the center whilst also improving the
user experience of the site for staff
and patients who visit the health center
in stradbroke this project has been
collaboratively worked on and agreed
with the integrated care board and
residence and has full support thank you
and the recommendation for that is for
approval
um
third bed is M22 hyphen 17.
in Stow Upland this is a new footpath
between Trinity Meadows to Trinity walk
bus stop
it's a sill bed of 14 200 pounds
and that represents a hundred percent of
the total project costs
the details are
over to you
could see please there is a planning
background to the provision of this
footpath uh it was requested by planning
committee on an approved in development
involving an uplift of an additional 19
dwellings uh following a second
application on adjoining land for 80
dwellings there was an opportunity to
connect the new site to the new footpath
the developers agreed to bridge the
ditch between the two types but they
would not agree to extend the path
Beyond this point as they did not own or
control the land necessary to complete
the link the district council owns this
land
given the need to secure a link from the
new development to the bus stop over
Council land as part of the planning
process this sill bid has come forward
from the estate service to provide the
necessary footpath
as you'll know District cell is
collected for the provision of
infrastructure to support new housing
growth and in this case it is entirely
appropriate to allow the use of
districts still to address and fully
fund the provision of the required
footprint following consultation with
the two board members revisions to the
exact route of the now being produced
and the route is amended in order to
address Ward member concerns thank you
thank you and again we recommend
approval
we recommend the cabinet to approve that
uh
a little bit
um
Now we move on to M22 hyphen 23 which is
a lavatory project in hoxon church
this is a sill bid for 28 000
um and 90 pounds
88 Pence and represents 75 percent of
the total eligible project costs
um Christine if you could give some
detail on that please
thank you there are currently know
accessible other toilet public toilet
facilities and hooks and when built
these facilities will be open to use for
members of the church congregation local
residents and importantly visitors to
the Village it does represent an oven
ready scheme with evidence of why
Community Support together with funding
contributions from hoxon parochial
Church Council thank you
thank you very much and and again the
recommendation is for cabinet to approve
that bid
um moving on to
m224 uh Barham Kirby green
excuse me this is um for fencing
it's a still bit of 3
377 pounds 75 representing 75 of the
total project eligible costs
this decision has been made under
delegated powers and is therefore for
cabinet to note only
um there are some details around this
one and I ask you to let us know what
they are please Christine
thank you this stupid as you say is for
fencing only the play area is now in use
but the word conserve safety concerns
for the area and The Wider field that
were raised this project will look to
increase the safety of the field for
both children and parents who are using
the site thank you
um
so this is the silver that's been
approved under delegated thousand
s on this note
um
and finally we have
a bit number n22 Haitian 28 in Mendham
this is for the Improvement of a car
park and the increase of spaces there
from 18 to 22.
the seal bed is for
9733 pounds 81 Pence and this represents
75 percent of the total eligible project
costs
the details of that Christine will tell
us please
the lack of of off-road parking
facilities and roadside parking issues
are ongoing issues for residents and and
visitors to the Village the street car
park is the only car park in the village
uh and the surface has begun to
disintegrate and it's it is riddled with
potholes um these are a trip Hazard for
all car park users uh improving the
surface but also increasing the amount
of spaces will help to reduce the amount
of roadside parking and congestion
within the village
thank you
thank you very much
um as I say this this bit has been
approved under delegated powers to note
only
um but the recommendation to cabinets
under paragraph say point one of the
report is to approve
um all those bids for cabinet the for to
decide and to for the two to be noted
um
and there is also a recommendation for
cabinet to note and endorse the silk
expenditure program which is given the
appendix a under paragraph 3.2
thank you Joe
thank you councilor do we have a second
I'm happy to Second chair and I think
there's projects are all worthy of our
um granting thank you
do we have any questions
councilman
yeah thank you chair um
no problems with any of those bids all
sounds great my question is sort of a
wider one about the seal process and
looking at appendix a we have a large
number of outstanding bids stacking up
so my question is um
those bids are not values currently we
hope obviously they will become valid
what's the hold up is it mostly to do
with external bodies providing the
information that's required to make the
bid valid
um
I'll leave it there that's the question
I think
yes thank you councilman
um
the detail of those individual beds and
the reasons why they're
um
why they're still on the books as it
were
it's a fairly complex situation I will
pass that over to the professional lead
if you don't mind thank you
each sober generally is different and
they come in from different sources
whether they be for a charity
organizations or from parishes or from
infrastructure providers
sometimes not all the information is
submitted at the time when the bid is
lodged and we work collaboratively
so better in order to get that scheme to
a point where we can
sometimes silk beds also don't have all
the money secured necessary to land the
project so we are sometimes also waiting
for other funders to agree their funding
before we can move forward it's a myriad
of things really
um yeah so if I can ask a supplementary
question
um understand the complexity totally I
get that um
is is it uh
clearly we want to move these these bids
forward are we making enough progress in
moving them forward or or is it held up
by outside bodies I suppose the question
is around do we have enough capacity to
to move them forward ourselves where we
can
foreign
there is certainly sufficient capacity
within the Seal team to move things
forward and other internal teams where
they are the council's own bids where
they are not then it very much depends
upon it's kind of
tolstoy's law every happy family is
alike every unhappy family is unheard
unhapp's own way every sill bid is
unique and individual in its own way
some depend on the bidder themselves
some depend on the other funders that
they are bringing in so the majority are
based on the either the capacity or the
clarity of outside bodies to move things
forward where they're internal and we do
have sufficient officer resource in
order to do that
cancel the field
thank you I hope I'm not answering the
same question again in a different way
but let's first of all at a strategic
level I think and notice on page 80
that we have
strategic fans of 2.4 million available
today of which 33 as a third are
allocated
we have a
the next fan the ring ring fence
Founders six million of which we have
slightly over a third 35 percent and
the local infrastructure found two and a
half million of which we've got again
slightly over a third allocated
really bearing in mind that these funds
are there to provide infrastructure
which improves the
environment for us all
are we really happy that this is a good
enough progress we're not talking about
just one sill bid round here we're doing
about bid rounds one to nine so that's
everything up to date
and we only have a third of the money
actually out there being used
so that's question one if I might try
another one in a moment
always satisfied with that right to put
out of activity
excuse me I do take that point um
which I think is
um
a valid a very valid uh criticism to to
make
um
but
I think it is a question of the
complexities and um
I wonder if uh I wonder if the director
for
which one of you would like to to handle
it to take that one then please Christy
thank you
um yes we do
we but since we started spending which
was only in 2018 we have allocated 10.8
million
um to 36 projects we have done three
primary schools we have done three high
schools not to mention working on on big
projects uh like Rail and health beds
and we do have 49 projects listed in the
emerging project bit of your appendix a
so there is a huge weight of work coming
forward which we are collaboratively
working on as members will be aware who
are engaged with some of this work
developing projects and shaping them
before they come in as silver it takes
quite some time but we are regularly
meeting with infrastructure providers
and all the the bidders on the on the
list of outstanding bids that we have so
I'm confident that we've got enough
projects to spend the money that we we
have and we have more we
thank you does anybody wish to could I
return to this that's the field one
if you don't mind
okay
thank you for that
the issue I had is again he's looking at
these there's a several bids here which
I'm not sure like all members there's
several here that aren't quite aware of
it's one of my good point that there's
one here on page one two one for for
balham Parish meeting
a bid which I think I persuaded them to
go forward with
um and there's a whole series of things
although they've got quotes the
Project's not really various thresholds
and the business case hasn't been
submitted
I I'm really surprised particularly
because the same sort of comments
around the bid for little Blake in them
Parish rooms
which I've watched the pain over a
number of years as that project has
desperately tried to move forward
have been impeded not least by the
church you wouldn't give them a lease
for a long time
and actually you know there are other
projects in this this area
similar sort of things
the high school sports Hall extension
down at um
for
um
Clayton High School for instance
the whole emphasis seems to be we have
difficulty in making progress
and the two I mentioned
um you know Wally binder who runs a
little bike and is
experiment of binders the company
Kevin Thomas who runs byland Parish
um
Council now
is
you used to run a large chunk of 3ms in
Germany so these are experienced
businessmen who are failing to get
through the process and it really
concerns me that
really the question is what is the
problem why as you expressed there's a
whole rafter work there to do but our
progress towards getting done seems to
be slow so
there's a response to that thank you
um
yes I I clearly can't can't comment on
on individual cases such as the ones
that you've mentioned because I I'm not
as
familiar with them as
as the officers are
um
but I think I think a lot of the problem
is is to do with the fact that there are
um
generally speaking quite quite a number
of players involved in the handling of
any any particular sill bid
and it's not just how I turn around
times that um uh
the the
delay or or speed up the processing
um as as the Director has just told you
you know we we are resourced well enough
to be able to handle these things
ourselves because when they're passed
over to other bodies that um uh the
speed at which they operate
cannot be controlled by by us and we
just have to we just have to play play
the game with them as as as they
dictated I mean I think I'm more or less
right in saying that but if if the
director would like to add anything to
it or a professional lead then please do
foreign
yes as a as I said each each beard each
application for sale funding is unique
in its own ways they're delivered on the
whole either by professional bodies
whether that's a particular GP practice
or the County council with education
bids the community level infrastructure
can be more complex but we have had a
number of applications that have met the
requirements the member working group on
the expenditure framework has met
a number of times to discuss the
requirements scrutiny have looked over
this a couple of times and had
communication directly from
bid makers the council does need to be
assured that it is spending its money
both efficiently and effectively and
that bids can
deliver the infrastructure that is being
asked I think I would be very wary of
taking an approach whereby we were
allocating seal money only to be sat in
a similar environment and meeting with
councilors saying you've allocated an
awful lot of seal money but it's not
coming forward
are we allocating to projects that
aren't oven ready and aren't ready to go
and haven't got their other funding in
place or their planning permission in
place so I think there's been a very
deliberate approach to ensure that seal
money is not kind of
held up and allocated to projects that
might take two three four years to
actually come to fruition but we are
able and willing to work with Community
groups the two councilor field that
you've identified have both had meetings
with officers one in December and one
more recently in January of this year
as the director for the service I'm not
aware of particular noise from those
particular communities saying that there
is there are unreasonable or or
unnecessarily onerous requests being
made of them
which are starving their ability to
bring these bids forward but
as you'll be aware probably more so than
most offices when working within
communities different things take
priority at different times and they
work at different Paces depending upon
the voluntary effort that that's often
being given by those that are
responsible for delivering it so
those communities are responsible the
the parish rooms are responsible for
upgrading the parish rooms and the
council will seek to support them where
it is appropriate
we're not seeking overly
judicial judicious amounts of
information from those people other than
to satisfy ourselves that the monies are
ready to spend and will be spent
appropriately
um but if you want me to pick up a
conversation with either of those groups
then I'm happy to do so alongside the
Seal team the council does also have its
communities team with its locality
offices with its
and others and quite often with silvids
there's a coming together of seal
funding and Community grants funding so
support is there and available but if
you want to pick up any individual
we sell outside of the meeting
thank you thank you very much thank you
I'm going to move us on
we've had three questions that are all
been the same
and move us on to debate does anybody
wish to debate this item
councilor Whitehead
thank you
I'd just like to say that I'm hard to
see that the book of these projects
um clearly the district council is
working hand in glove with the parish
councils or the parochial Church Council
in one case
um to make these improvements to local
community I think it's good to see that
the past
are putting some money into this into
these projects
um although it's not clear whether
that's from precept or from their local
sill I think it'd be quite useful going
forward if we could see whether the
parish council's um contributions are
they're still all from you know precepts
to Residents but I say I think um I
think a question in the past before
where some projects seem to be almost
100 funded from
you know from our district cell and I
think it's hardly to see that Parish
councils working closely on these
projects
Council flowers
um yes
um
I've had a few still bids um coming
through and I could I totally understand
where Avan ready
um
comes from because if you've not done
all your homework and you've not filled
in the forms and you haven't got your
funding in hand then you know it's going
to take longer so if you get all your
um
all your Ducks lined up if you like and
then you go for your beard
um to the still team then anything that
little little bits and pieces they can
advise you and I mean you know my
parishes have only found the Seal team
very very helpful indeed thank you
thank you
thank you thank you very much members
um so the recommendations are as
detailed in the report on too long
lengthy to read them all out again so
I'm just going to go straight to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
that's unanimous
um I'm now going to go for a quick break
to
um what did you go and warm up
five five minutes so it's 11 46 if we're
back in here at five to twelve that'd be
great thank you very much
thank you
welcome back everybody we're now moving
on to item 12. which is MCA slash 22-52
the private sector housing enforcement
and civil penalties pop policy
invite the cabinet member for housing to
introduce this report councilor
headingham
thank you
this report relates to maintaining and
improving House housing standards in the
private rented sector the private
renting sector contributes towards
meeting housing need in the district
most landlords provide good standard
accommodation for their tenants and
manage their property satisfaction
satisfactorily but this is not so in all
cases the report proposes a new
enforcement policy for our private
sector housing work it outlines the
current work of our housing standards
team which is responsible for ensuring
that housing conditions are self safe
and hate healthy for residents which is
the statutory Council Duty
and it taught the enforcement policy
seeks to provide Clarity for landlords
and agents on what is expected from them
and the response they can expect from
the council to service requests
in most cases this involves advice and
encouragement to meet minimum legal
standards the policy also outlines Gap
guidelines for officers to ensure
enforcement is taken consistently fairly
and using good and fair practice
wherever possible we prefer to work with
landlords in order to resolve problems
to improve standards
offices occasionally come across
situations where housing conditions are
extremely poor and vulnerable vulnerable
people are left at unacceptable risk to
their safety and health for example poor
fire safety precautions in houses in
multiple occupation oh occupation
inadequate Heating and overcrowding
sometimes officers encounter situations
where they need to use formal powers in
most extreme cases officers work with
other agencies such as the police and
fire service and have been actively
dealing with dangerous and have been
active and have been active dealing with
dangerous and criminal activities
relating to rented housing such as
modern day slavery in our districts the
report proposes to check to charge for
officer administrative administrative
time to recover costs where formal
action must be taken when it has to
resort to using such powers
this policy is not intended to prescribe
the action that would be taken into
every situation it will guide officers
when investigating cases serving notices
or taking enforcement action including
legal proceedings
it is important that officers have the
option to make use of all powers
available to them
the government has given powers to local
authorities to take strong action where
it is Justified in the private rented
sector
these are known as civil penalties and
are an alternative to prosecution
alternative sorry to prosecution they
enable us to penalize the worst
landlords through direct Financial
Financial sanctions I can't speak or
prosecution and will only be used in
serious offenses or where compliance
cannot be achieved
the council has developed civil
penalties approach in appendix 2 or
after collaboration with colleagues in
Suffolk and liaison with our legal
department this will ensure that
penalties are proportionate to the
offense and applied fairly there is a
system of receiving
representations against the imposition
and refine and legal appeal against
available in all these cases
it is in line with the government's
intention to prevent landlords from
benefiting from unlawful Behavior the
council intends to use his Paris
sparingly only when Justified and
generally where enforcement action has
failed to obtain compliance any
penalties received will be retained in
the team's budget
I recommend members to um to agree on
option one as states in the paragraphs
3.1 to 3.5 this is to adopt the new
private rented sector housing and policy
including approving and authorizing the
use of civil and financial penalty
Powers it is also to agree a fair
charging regime to recover the cost of
housing enforcement action taken by the
council and to retain Revenue arising
from civil penalties the reason for
agreeing the recommendation the reason
for agreeing the recommendations are to
ensure that the council has a consistent
and effective policy to tackle poor
conditions in the private sector housing
thank you very much
thank you girls for having me do you
have a second
I'm happy to Second share Council
Platinum thank you very much
do we have any questions from cabinet
questions from anybody else
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay uh in which case the
recommendations are to agree option one
above
um
I'm not going to read all these out it's
too long
so recommendations are option 3.1 3.2
3.3 3.4 3.5 and I'm going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
[Music]
that is six votes for that's unanimous
excellent thank you very much
item 13
MCA slash 22 53 this is the update on
the social housing regulation and the
outcome of the referral to the regulator
of social housing
and I'm going to invite the county
member for housing to introduce this
report
thank you very much this paper provides
an update on our work around social
around social housing regulation and
compliance following our referral to the
regulative social housing
the social housing regulation to ensure
we meet our obligations we must have a
government governance structure the
regulator expects members to have
oversight of all compliance issues which
include gas inspections electrical
safety checks fire safety asbestos and
Legionella lifts
in addition following the tragic events
in Rochdale The Regulators concluded
that dampen role must be reported by our
governance structure
structure where compliance is reported
at cabinet would give assurance that
members have oversight this forms part
of the consumer standards and is
critical
the consumer standards cover all aspects
of housing therefore as with the
building therefore as with the building
service performance the housing team
will be reporting high-level kpis
this paper sets out the suggested format
and the referral following our
self-referral and subsequent regulated
judgment The Regulators said they will
give us time to work on our compliance
and contact us in a month as such we
have not yet received correspondence
from the regulator thank you very much
thank you councilor headingham and I'm
very happy to Second this report
do we have any questions from cabinet
questions from anybody else
does anybody wish to debate disciple
okay so the recommendations are to note
the update on recent changes to the
regulation of social outing including
for a stockholding local authorities
to note the outcome of the council's
recent referral to the regulator of
social housing
to agree the future governance and
monitoring Arrangements set out at
paragraph seven of this report
to agree the new set of kpis for the
housing service set out in paragraph six
of this report
and I'm going to invite the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
councilor Ben are you experiencing any
issues with the voting
thank you councilor burn that is six
boots four and that's unanimous
lovely thank you very much indeed
item 14
MCA slash 22 54 is the baber and
mid-suffolk culture Heritage and visitor
economy
ecology
and invite the cabinet member for
economic growth to introduce the report
councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair I am delighted
to introduce paper MCA slash 22-54 The
Joint culture Heritage and visitor
economy strategy
this strategy sets out our Ambitions
aims and objectives of mid-suffic for
the next five years and will be followed
by detailed delivery plan by June of
this year
within mid-suffolk we have a strong and
vibrant cultural sector supported by
popular and well-established Heritage
assets both of which contribute
significant sums to our local economy as
I hope you can see uh
detailed in the papers as a council we
have been proactive in supporting
culture Heritage and tourism
from the Regal Theater the John peel
Center to the new Duck and teapot in
Needham Market but what this strategy
seeks to do is provide a comprehensive
and informative vision for how we can
develop this sector further
section five of the report outlines the
process through which the strategy has
been developed including extensive
stakeholder engagement in a number of
workshops a detailed evidence base
covering both baber and mid-suffolk and
a cross-party working group to help
inform this strategy
the evidence-based at this strategy
draws on Highlights the areas for
improvement a notable skills Gap being
one of them but rather than being a
purely technocratic document I think
this strategy goes some way to help
Define our identity as a district rural
steeped in history and with strong
communities with a proud sense of place
I think the feedback contained within
this report reflects that but there is
one particular point that I do want to
highlight as I think it also goes to the
heart of why we are introducing this
strategy
which is on page eight of the strategy
itself which refers to mid-suffolk as
the white space of Suffolk
and I know this is One Singular comment
and it is valuable in understanding how
we are perceived but I passionately
disagree with that summary of
mid-suffolk there is a wealth of
cultural and historical offerings within
our district and so we're proposing this
uh strategy uh I hope it will provide us
with an opportunity to shine a light on
those offerings to help develop them
further and to Champion them locally
regionally and nationally
so I'm delighted to propose the
recommendations in this report and would
seek a seconder thank you chair
the second up
do we have any questions from cabinet
questions from anybody else
councilor Miller
um I'm sure I can actually turn this
into a question but um
having read the uh the strategy I think
it's really great
just leave it there
thank you very much
can you respond to that chair if you
like it I agree wholeheartedly thank you
go ahead
um does anybody wish to debate this item
and I'd just like to reiterate my my
support my thanks to our officers as
well we we have had a
joint
joint a working party sorry cross party
working party
um on this
um so I'm really really pleased that it
has your everybody's full support so
thank you very much officers you've done
a fantastic job on this
uh I'm just going to invite the officers
to conduct the vote thank you
that vote is now in progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on now to item 15 and this is MCA
slash 22 55 the approval to consult on a
revised table Affairs for Hackney
carriages
in the absence of counselor Fleming I'm
going to introduce this report
purpose of this report is to provide
some background to the recent assessment
of options for modifying the Hackney
Carriage maximum Affairs and to
introduce the rationale for proposing
option two as the preferred option
the consultation was carried out with a
Hackney Carriage Trade to determine
whether there should be an increase to
the maximum fare that can be charged and
if so what this increase should be
refer to
for the four options presented views
will also sought from the trade as to
whether there should be one tariff for
both mid-suffolk and both baber
a majority of responders 59 preferred
option two with option 4 following with
20 percent
option two gives the trade the greatest
scope to increase fares as they see fit
with some degree of flexibility
given the level of support this is what
is being recommended to Cabinet today
during the consultation it was confirmed
that the meters in Midsouth at are set
to measure different units of distance
than those in baber and cannot be
adjusted to make the systems consistent
therefore it is not currently practical
to impose the same tariffs of course the
two districts
as such further consultation was
conducted with the mid-suffolk taxi
trade and the proposed tariff reflecting
option two and attached it appendix a of
the report was agreed as the preferred
new fair schedule
a report was presented to the Licensing
and Regulatory committee on the 3rd of
February and their decision was to
recommend a cabinet that they adopt the
revised table Affairs but to also
include the calculations on the table in
metric and miles in order to assist
members of the public
these changes are reflected in the
proposed table Affairs at appendix a
further to this recommendation the
Licensing and Regulatory committee
recommended the cabinet request the
licensing team to investigate the costs
and practicalities of replacing the
mid-suffic meters and to report back to
the Licensing and Regulatory committee
at a later date
under Section 165 of the local
government miscellaneous Provisions act
1976 should cabinet decide to adopt the
revised table Affairs the fares must be
advertised in a local newspaper and on
the council's website allowing 14 days
for consultation
if no objections are received the
approved charges can take effect
projections are received and cannot be
resolved then the meta must be returned
to committee for consideration
and I'd just like to point out a typing
error in your pages in your paper pack
in your packs page 319
the row on tariff 3
the final column
where it says 0.20 mile
that should be amended to which to be
naught Point naught five
seek a second
of counselor Richardson happy to Second
thank you chair thank you councilor
do we have any questions from covenant
do we have any questions for anybody
else
do we
does anybody wish to debate this item
base at the recommend I
recommendations
are it is recommended the cabinet
following consideration of Licensing and
Regulatory committee's recommendation
approves the revised table of fares for
consultation
attached at appendix a to this report
and in accordance with Section 65 of the
local government miscellaneous
Provisions act 1976 this was consulted
as option two with the taxi trade
it is recommended that cabinet following
consideration of Licensing and
Regulatory committee's recommendation
request the licensing team to
investigate the modernization of Hackney
Carriage meters
all findings are to be reported back to
the Licensing and Regulatory committee
at a later date
with regular with delegated authority to
develop a delivery plan to be completed
by June to
so I'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
he said that vote is now in progress
thank you chair that is six foot four
that's unanimous
lovely thank you very much
next is item 16 this is MCA slash
22-55 the skills and The Innovation
Center on Gateway 14. this report
contains confidential appendices
so if members wish to question and
debate the appendices we will have to go
into a closed session
before the debate and where we'll come
back to open session to take the vote so
I'm now going to invite the cabinet
member for economic growth to introduce
this report
foreign
thank you very much chair I'm delighted
to introduce paper MCA slash 22-56 the
skills and Innovation Center at Gateway
14. as you said check contained within
the appendices is the initial business
case for the center and the ask cabinet
today is to note this and endorse the
decision to proceed to a full business
case
members will be well aware that our
aspiration for Gateway 14 exceeds beyond
the significant sums of inward
investment and the thousands of jobs
that it now offers numerous studies of
course have identified a skills Gap
within within Suffolk and mid-suffolk in
particular and Gateway 14 offers offers
us a once in a generation opportunity to
address this
we know too that Innovation is a key
driver of growth jobs and wages and as
an Administration I believe we must do
everything we can to create the
conditions in which innovation can
flourish
the appendices sets out in detail how we
aim to achieve this through the skills
and Innovation Center but I will list
the key components now namely a
technology-enabled learning environment
modular and micro learning a local labor
market Observatory letter will grow on
spaces and flexible meeting rooms and
Conference facilities
such an offering would help reinforce
Gateway 14 as one of if not the most
exciting economic development in the
east of England
further as part of Freeport East the
opportunities presented by the skills
and Innovation Center will help Drive
economic growth across our district
county and The Wider region
as you will see from the appendices
significant progress has already been
made including out on the detailed
design of the scheme and the extensive
evidence base that underpins these
proposals but there is much work still
to be done to develop this fully
dependency sets out the various gateways
through which the ski would need to pass
before becoming a reality and it is for
this reason that I'm asking cabinet to
endorse the decision to proceed on this
basis both myself and officers here are
happy to ask answer any questions on the
detail contained within the appendices
but obviously chair that one then Intel
going into the closed session but if
there are any questions that can be
dealt with in public session then I'm
also happy to take those questions for
I'm delighted to propose the
recommendations in this report therefore
and will ask for a second though thank
you
thank you
um do we have any questions from cabinet
any questions from anybody else
no
anybody wish to debate this item
okay
so the recommendations are the cabinet
review and note the initial business
case attached as appendix a the
confidential paper including high level
development appraisal with initial
costing estimates Revenue income
opportunities and viability requirements
indicative costs of borrowing and latest
version of the scheme design layout
including an indicative schedule of
accommodation
cabinet note the work to date on the
operational management strategy and the
findings and conclusion of the risk
publico report which is attached as
annexf1 of appendix a
cabinet endorsed the option to further
develop a business case for Combined
skills and Innovation Center
a cabinet note the forward funding of
Revenue spend from within existing
budgets to complete the next stage of
business case development work
it should be noted that where
forward-funded Revenue spend can be
later capitalized it will be
so I'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
I'm sorry thank you chair that vote is
now in progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
that unanimous
thank you everybody
what we're doing to our climate
initiative producing uh
having too much heating on it once
so this is the final cabinet meeting of
this term so I'd just like to take this
opportunity of saying a really big thank
you to a cabinet our opposition members
here keeping us keeping us sane
and also especially especially to all of
our officers who attend regularly and
support us in our endeavors to keep our
residents and our tourists and our
businesses or safe and everything
working smoothly
now that this is as I said this is the
final cabinet meeting of this term so
the next cabinet meeting
will be on the 12th of June
thank you
we're just going to do item 17.
to the
option to go into closed session and
just to clarify that the appendices are
exempt and confidential I'm just going
to hand over to our monitoring officer
for clarification
yes thank you thank you
Jim it was just to absolutely clarify
that those appendices are confidential
because at the end of this meeting
someone could put in an foi request and
say well you didn't you didn't actually
so going forward we just need to do that
obviously it's an ongoing Duty for the
council to keep looking at its
appendices to see if they're
confidential but at this precise moment
they are confidential so
so if we just revisit well not really we
just move on to item 17 and pass the
resolution or don't pass the resolution
to make those documents out
okay I could just read out item 17
that's that's the way to do it
so to consider whether pursuant to part
one of schedule 12a of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified Below on the grounds
that if the public were present during
this item it is likely that there would
be disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against the
item
the author of this report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda
satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption outweighs the
public interest in in disclosing the
information so that is appendices a b
and c
I propose exemption can I have a second
of please councilor Richardson happy to
second that chat
um all in favor just raise your hand
please
thank you
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you okay thank you I apologize for the
confusion so the next meeting of the new
term will be Monday the 12th of June at
10 30. thank you very much everybody